he set a record in the gym by
temporarily being a her instead of a him
a male power lifter recently entered a
women's event in Canada and smashed the
bench press record held by a trans
athlete
but how you ask was a guy allowed to
compete with women turns out in Canada
which fox has confirmed is a real place
their powerlifting Union allows athletes
to sign up for any gendered event based
on how they feel no questions asked
Biden has a similar policy when it comes
to hiring people in his administration
I do like them yeah
the bearded Beefcake Avi silverberg who
is very much a man identified as a woman
to enter the competition his goal was
simple show how unfair it is for
biological males to compete against
women and boy did he competing in the
bench press silverberg easily beat the
old record by nearly 100 pounds
which converts in Canadian currency to
one crate of maple syrup
the best part several records in the
Canadian women's division are held by a
woman who used to be a man this is that
lifter I mean standard bench in
powerlifting competition for women I
literally don't understand why it's so
bad
my son he weighs 45 pounds his max bench
is like 33. I'm Legit seeing some women
in competition who are doing
something like 50 pounds and I just
don't understand it
that person was actually there to watch
her records get crushed so haha
how does it feel
and so it proves an important point
about women's sports that maybe it's
time to take the spotlight off
biological men and put it back where it
belongs on lesbians
go lesbians
we are pro-lesbian here
tires as a weight lifter how do stories
like these make you feel well I hate
that he had to make that point yeah but
I'm glad that he did and if I could just
answer Sweetheart's question the reason
why they only bent 50 pounds and
compared to the body weight and stuff
because they're women they're not built
that way
all about upper body strength but I I
hope this put on alarm I hope this it
might take a few of these situations
where and it's ironic because it turns
out the best feminist in this situation
is a powerlifting alpha male yeah so
thank you sir for your feminism
and hopefully we have more men to go you
know what you're not going to come in
here maybe we need a couple you know
maybe need a couple male swimmers from
former Olympic athletes or or come over
just for the meats that that yeah she's
in just just to level the playing field
exactly just do and I'm I'm pretty sure
she won't want to compete anymore
because she'll just like when she
competed at 80 Place 80th Place that's
not even a thing yeah and then hopped
over so maybe she'll hop back yeah cat
you know you are obviously a fitness
icon
you must have a message for Canadian
female power lifters everywhere
they do they see me icon I think they do
she's wiry yeah she's wiry you hold a
record in uh holding on uh just sitting
on a bench
story in high school them we did a
weightlifting portion of gym class yes
and they had to create a whole new like
routine for me because I couldn't lift
the bar up
you could you lift up a bar now like the
basic bar you probably couldn't I don't
think I've gotten stronger no I don't
think so I mean I don't think I could I
don't want to try I'm older now I might
might break something yeah
so this beautiful lady
um
beat the record of the other woman who
was born a man right who has the vagina
record I don't know
that's a great point
I kept waiting for it in the segment and
this person with a vagina lifted this
much
I feel like that should be more easily
accessible information yeah exactly and
is that what they're gonna have to call
it the vagina lifter
she just solved this whole problem no
you did yeah because we can just change
it it's not gender vagina
penis stats
you seriously Take a Bow who is who is
the number one Canadian vagina lifter
you leading with us on Fox and Friends
I'll lead with it I will lead with it at
6 a.m on Saturday
it's not gonna work because this is a
reality bending game based upon changing
definitions do you think they're all
going to agree on with the definition of
a vagina is yeah
they were happy to tell them
[Laughter]
[Applause]
that this lady beat this dude beat the
other dude the other dude the other
dude's been through the procedures yeah
right like all of them surgical which
don't get me wrong I'm not saying that
makes him a woman but he's gonna try to
twist your standard no matter what what
it is so that he can go win in whatever
it is you know uh uh Todd I'm really
glad your parents weren't in the
audience today for a vagina record yes I
was worried you guys were going to go to
the full screen of me when she said
vagina
records seem like you would like to do
sounds like something I play when I'm
alone put on the vagina record
[Laughter]
damn it's terrible this is what happens
but you know what I like about it I like
pranks that have a little bit of wisdom
or a prank that actually
exposes kind of like the absurdity of
things around him it's I would say it's
kind of harmful it's a harmless thing
but it had knowledge to bear I would
wouldn't go so far as harmless and I'm
actually worried that other people are
going to see this and say wow this was
an entree we can do the same thing based
upon the left's own ridiculous
definitions of what constitute a man or
what constitutes a woman and my concern
is that this isn't just prizes there's
money oftentimes attached with these
competitions and as well well knows
being a sports guy when you remove money
out of a sport that sport is going to go
away and my concern is that women's
sports will go away once you remove the
money and as the father of two girls
that worries me I know I'm blowing a
story about vagina records into
something serious but as a father of two
girls my concern is that you know so
their Sports could go away yeah that's
true all right let's move on shall we
that was fun
up next give English a chance says JD
van hey Sean Hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to Fox News YouTube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else